When my doctor ran blood work, he said that I have low thyroid because my TSH was slightly elevated.
Should I increase my thyroid medication based upon that?
No. No, you shouldn't.
So
I see this a lot. A person gets a blood test
from their practitioner and they run a thyroid test, and they will they tell the person
that they read a thyroid test, and all they read is a TSH. So understand, TSH is thyroid
stimulating hormone. It's not secreted by your thyroid. It's secreted by your pituitary.
Because your hypothalamus senses your level of thyroid hormone in the blood. What is that?
Well, you have free T3, which is the active thyroid hormone in the blood.
And that's what's sensed. If it is low, it will tell the pituitary to secret thyroid
stimulated hormone to get your thyroid to stimulate to stimulate more hormone. Your thyroid
secretes thyroid hormone primarily in the four of what's called T4. 95% of what's secreted
is in T4. 5% is in the active form of T3. Well, T4 will then convert to T3 in the gut and in the liver.
So sometimes when a person does have low thyroid, technically low thyroid is defined by having
low T3. So if a person has low free T3 and low total T3, then you would look at why? It can
be because of a conversion problem. Maybe they have high or high normal T4. It's not converting
to T3. Well, then you got to fix the person's gut and work on the person's liver. That can also
give a person an elevated TSH. So again, you would give the person more thyroid hormone based upon
elevated TSH alone. If the person had elevated TSH, low T3 and low T4, then they probably need
an increase in their dose of thyroid medication. But if by just doing a blood test and showing TSH
alone without running the rest of a full thyroid profile, again, I'm sorry, but this bothers me
because this is bad practice. We'll just say bad practice. It's just wrong. It's not getting a good
evaluation of what's going on. Sorry, but it's just not good. Dr. Reed,
comment by a person, a person who asked this question. Our friend had the scanner
brought it to our house and ran the test. I just apologize. I don't want to mean anything
mean to your friend or anything, but I just don't think they're, they can be good for scanning
to see, oh, maybe I should test them. Do a proper test like a blood test or a urine test, a laboratory.
That's an accredited, clear, approved lab. It's hard to get that accreditation. And they're using
proper machinery to run your tested. Then, then I would say, then you could use it for that purpose,
but you don't diagnose off as I don't scan. You just don't. It's just not, that is, that is not
correct. That's not right practice. As much as it's not right practice to diagnose on a T,
a low thyroid on a TSH level. There's a lot of practitioners, maybe the majority of
practitioners, medical doctors, and alternative practitioners that do not understand how to manage
thyroid cases. I don't say that arrogantly. It's just, I've had a lot of training. It's
been all my money going to school. But you kind of do it. If you want to do it, it's right for people.
I just, I don't get it. I'm sorry.